hi there steve kaufman here again i'm uh
going off skiing for a week to big white
near kelowna
so i probably won't be doing any more
videos for a while
so i thought i would just do one here on
this whole subject of
of language acquisition versus language
learning and so forth which seems to
have
generated a bit of discussion on my blog
i am
a great admirer
of krashen
he igor in macedonia says that crash and
didn't originate these theories whatever
i've come across them by a crash and
when i read a lot of things that he
wrote i said yeah exactly that's how i
learn
um
but i don't
accept everything that he says
and one of the things where i i disagree
and it's not an important point really
but it's worth talking about and i'll
explain why and this is this whole issue
of learning a language versus acquiring
a language
and he sort of
and and many of the people who
write about language learning
try to say that there are two different
approaches one is learning which is
serious and deliberate and learning
about the grammar and the other is
acquisition which is something that we
do naturally and some people think that
only
children acquire their first language
whereas thereafter it's a more
deliberate learning process but they
still therefore talk about a dichotomy
crash and suggest that we continue to be
in fact
acquiring the language rather than
learning it
to me
i don't like it i don't like the use of
the word acquire because what is the
choir if i say you acquire something
means you bought it you took it
and it then became yours and you put it
away somewhere
the word learn to me
simply means that the brain is learning
and i don't like the association of
learning with the classroom with school
with teachers
with exercises drills tests all of the
formal formalized
uh
ceremonies that we seem to have
attached to learning
to me learning is as described in the
book by manfred spitzer which i highly
recommend
it's called
learning
and the brain
or the school for life or something like
that you can look it up on amazon
our brain learns all the time
our brain learns by establishing
patterns
uh it's not just the left side of the
brain or the rational side of the brain
all different parts of the brain get
involved emotion gets involved and
through a process of repetition and and
this whole business of
neurons firing with each other and then
again and again and creating these
connections which form these patterns so
that the brain then after a while
doesn't have to rediscover everything
because it's got a lot of patterns in
place and this process of learning is
how we learn about experience how we
learn to deal with people how we learn
to walk so we don't fall down all the
things that we learn and
and as we get older we have more and
more of these patterns in place because
we've come across them more often
younger people are still discovering
things and they're starting to become
patterns
and so everything is learning
uh but learning doesn't mean that you
necessarily hold on to it it goes in
you might forget it you might know it
for a while and forget it
uh the brain might i don't know i'm not
a neurologist or from what i've read
might discard things that they don't the
brain doesn't come across too often and
yet for some strange reason the brain is
capable of remembering things that you
learned a long long time ago and don't
need anymore
so it's a as i said it's sort of a
random process whereby the brain tries
to sort through
all of the stimulus that it gets puts
labels on things develops patterns rules
this is what this is learning learning
is not sitting in a classroom learning
goes on all the time
so language learning
is the same whether it's a child
learning its first language or an adult
sure there are different circumstances
the child has no other language
to interfere
because when we already have our own
language we have a tendency
to go back to what is already hardwired
in our brain in terms of structures
pronunciation and so forth the child
doesn't have this interference on the
other hand an older person learning they
have their existing vocabulary their
life experience
which helps them learn in a different
way but it's still learning and i don't
accept any distinction between
acquisition and learning to me it's all
learning
so that's one point by the same token
this learning is a natural process but
crashing to my mind that some of the
ardent believers in his approach
including my good friend igor in
macedonia believe they believe that it's
just a matter of naturally listening and
reading and you will acquire it i don't
believe that
i think that there has to be a number of
other factors have to come into play
particularly when we're older because as
the child learning
his or her first language it's just
natural they want to communicate they
hear it there's no other language there
patterns are starting to form in the
brain and whatever but when we're older
we have to make a more deliberate effort
we have to want to learn the language we
have to try to
project ourselves we have to want to
communicate with those people all the
things the child does naturally we have
to try a little harder to do we have to
not worry about sounding foolish the
child doesn't care if the child sounds
childish the child is a child we don't
want to sound childish we don't like the
feeling that we're clumsy in another
language so we have to make a greater
effort to overcome these psychological
barriers first of all and the other
thing is that there are things in the
language that even with
the best of intention we don't notice
and i've seen this in my own learning
lots of times so it is helpful to me to
read through a grammar book
i read through it you know leave through
when i start don't intend to remember
anything but just get a general overview
of the language and at various times i
keep up
you know a book around my toilet when i
sit there on the can if you pardon me
leave through it and occasionally you
pick some stuff up but not with the
intention of of learning it so that you
can
you know pass a test on it
all the exercises and quizzes that they
have in those books i ignore them i just
quickly skim over what they have to say
about how the language works
most of which i forget
couldn't possibly remember it doesn't
really make sense
and yet by the fifth or sixth or seventh
time when i read it after a year or two
into the language in fact i'll notice
things even in terms of even though i've
read this thing three times before i
never noticed what they were saying and
then all of a sudden i'll notice it so
and that then helps me to notice it when
i'm listening or reading
in the language
and similarly
these various word lists that we go
through and ideally wordless that come
from our listening and reading reviewing
them in different ways
i like to review words before and after
i read the text and of course link
enables us to do that very easily i like
to occasionally go to my vocabulary
section at lincoln and look words up by
suffix by prefix
alphabetical just different things like
that that help me notice things on a
random basis there is no question in my
mind that the variety of these
activities and some people swear by
their anki and their
space repetition and all these different
things
help us to notice i still believe that
the bulk of our time has to be spent on
exposing it to the exposing us to the
language but to pretend that that it's
just a matter of listening really i
don't buy it i think that's the most
important thing to do we didn't worry
about what we can't remember we need to
try and save it for a test we shouldn't
test kids on language in school
but
we should
as learners and if we have students
encourage them to do things that help
them notice so there i also disagree
with crash
and the third thing and i also don't
agree with him about the idea that
immigrant children should first be learn
in their own language before learning
english i mean
there's lots of hispanic kids so they
might get away with doing it you're
going to do that for everybody it
doesn't make sense to me it makes much
more sense kids move to the united
states get with the program learn
english be as fluent as you possibly can
be in english and then worry about your
spanish when you have time
the other thing is there are people who
still don't believe that a lot of
listening and reading is better than
grammar learning
it is the brain learns i came across
some i was skiing i came across this
russian family and we spoke for a while
in russian i mean my russian was much
better than the parents english they've
been in canada for eight years
no question in my mind
that if those parents had done what i'd
done
spent the amount of time that i've spent
just listening and reading and occasing
flipping occasionally flipping through a
grammar book they would be further ahead
and if they had the determination to do
it
so it works maybe i'm better at it
because i've had ten languages nine
languages whatever but they would be
better off if they did what i did i'm
quite convinced nothing wrong with the
esl school that go there and they make
friends with people from other countries
and it helps them
you know
feel more comfortable in canada but in
terms of language learning if they were
on a program like i was on they would be
miles ahead
that's how they would learn and so they
would learn
and i don't nothing against the term but
i don't like this idea of a dichotomy
between acquisition and learning you
don't learn in school
you learn because the brain